生まれだっても同じことだと
輪廻は良くないんだと
とにかく解脱をしたいんだと
思ってる人がだからといって涅槃に入るわけじゃないんです
気持ちだけやるんだから涅槃ということはないんだからね
やっぱり悟らなくちゃいけないんですけどね
そういう人々はどうなるんですかと
天国に あなた天国に行きたいんですか？と
別にという気持ちでしょうし
じゃあ梵天に？別にどこ行ったって同じことだからと
私はずーっと頑張ったのは解脱を得たいと頑張ったんだけど
できなかったと そういう人は死ぬ時どうなるかというと
そういう人々の場合はこの
あの解脱を得たいと頑張っていたんだから
もう心が清らかであることは確かなんですね
そこであっち行きたいという強い欲もないんですね
天国に行きたい あっち行きたいという強い欲もない
どこでもいいや しょうがないという感じでいるんだから
その欲がない人の場合は
このカルマの力でその人に一番ふさわしいところを選んでくれるんです
例えば あの こういうこと
天国に行きたいと思ってる人の頭の中で
かすかに天国という概念が生まれるんですね
それは概念だけど 天国を体験したわけじゃないんですね
それは自分 今の世の中で経験した
あの いろいろ概念があるでしょう
天国はこんなものではないかと
それで その世界に生きていきたいと思っちゃうんですね
その人はそれですごい戒律を守ったり
修行したり 徳を積んだりとかね
かなりの膨大な徳を積むんです
積むんだけど 最後にこの人希望しているんだから
頭でイメージしている次元に合うところに生まれ変わっちゃうんです
で 人間でいえば 大体この人間が本当に立派に生きていたならば
この四天王のところぐらいです
もしもっと仏教の話とか
いろんなことを聞いて
天国の次元の差がわかっていて
もっと高いところに生きていきたいなと思っている人々がいるならば
高いところに行けますけどね
一般的にはそうならないんですね
我々は眼耳鼻舌身から情報を得て
その中で頭でイメージしてね
すごい幸福な次元をね
行きちゃい 行っちゃいますから
大体この六 六次元が 六次元がありますから
天界に 一番下の天界に行ける可能性はあるんですね
で 徳はそうじゃないんです
六番目の天界にも生まれる徳なんですけど
そこで生まれ変わることを希望していると
そうなっちゃうんです
希望してない人が 解脱を得たいという希望で生きている人の場合は
どこでもいいという感じですから
その場合はその人はどれぐらい徳を積んでいるかというカルマのエネルギーがあるんだ
あるんだから そのカルマのエネルギーにふさわしい心の次元ができちゃうんですね
ですから その人はかなり一番ふさわしいところに生まれ変わっちゃうんです
希望して している人は希望通りに生まれ変わっちゃう
ですから 一番正しい 道徳的に正しいと言えるのは
どこかで生まれ変わりたい
生まれ変わりたいという希望ではないんです
やっぱり輪廻を脱出したいという気持ちこそが一番高い道徳的な希望なんですね
そうすると輪廻に対して怖い
怖いと思う必要はないんです
その人にとてもふさわしいところに生まれ変わる
人間の界 人間界か天界かどこか
まあ一番ふさわしいところに生まれ変わる
自分で選んだら まあそこに行ってしまっちゃうと
それはもうお金持ってきて
このお金でこれ買いますか？と思った人には
まあそれ買うしか道がないし
決まってるんだからね
で お金はあるんだけど
どうしようかなと思った人にとっては
そのお金で買える 全部買ってしまっちゃう
ことになるんですね ですから無駄にならないね
財産が  今日の説明は このどうやって死ぬかっていうことはね
それすごい簡単 アユッキャエナ
寿命が終わったら人は死ぬ
寿命っていうのは そのその生命次元に決まられている
あの 寿命ですね それはあの変わるんですね
で 例えば昔の人々を昔っていうのは我々知ってる昔の人々は早く死んじゃったし
今の人々は結構長生きするし
で そういうふうに寿命ももう変わってしまっちゃいますけど
でも寿命が終わったら
まあどうせ死ぬ 例えば百二十とかね
それ以上はもうどう頑張ってもいられないんですね
いくら長生きしたっても
それから何でしたっけ
カッマッキャかな カッマッキャ
カルマのエネルギーが消えちゃったら死ななくちゃいけないんですね
だから我々はただ長生きする国で生まれたんだから長生きするというわけじゃないんですね
まだカルマでカルマのエネルギーで生かされてもらわないと生きていられない
ですから そのカルマのエネルギーは大変大事なもので
カルマのエネルギー 業が切れちゃったらもうすぐ死んじゃうということは
例えば百年寿命のもうすごい長生きできる家族で生まれたとする
でもその人のカルマが短いというと長生きできないんです
体が早く病気になってもう早く弱くなって死んでしまっちゃうんです
百年寿命があっても 業の力が五十年だったら五十年で死んじゃうんです
次に両者を作ると いわゆる業も終わって寿命も終わったところでも死んでしまっちゃう
四番目っていうのは突然死ぬ
業も残っている 寿命も残っている
それで突然死ぬ その四つの死に方
生命にあるんです その四つは人間にもありますけど
天国なんかはまた違うんですね
天国では大体寿命はいるんです
梵天だったら必ずしも寿命が終わるまでいるんです
そこで梵天で死ぬ人々は
業も寿命も両方終わってから死ぬ
天国もだいたい同じ あの業も寿命も両方終わってから死んじゃうんです
なぜならば 死ぬ他の原因がないんです
例えば天国に生まれたら風邪引くわけじゃないし
肺はないんだから もう肺炎になるわけでもないし
この消化器官何もないんだだから胃がんとかね
もうないんですね だからもう死ぬ原因はないんです
我々みたいな体持ってないんだから
ウイルスとかね 院内感染とかなんとかとか何もないんです B
型肝炎も何も そういうことで
それからこの食べ物とかね
食べ物悪い食べ 食べて体が壊れたということは人間にはあるんだけど
天界にはないんですね
なぜならば その決まっている栄養を受けるだけであって
他の栄養は受けません
ですから 栄養ももうきちんと決まっているものが入るんですから
そこは問題ないんですね
だから死ぬ原因はない
だから寿命が終わるまでいられる
業終わるまでいられる
人間は違うんですね いくら健康な体に生まれても
もう体にいい食べ物がなくなっちゃったら
何とか食べなくちゃいけない
それはもう汚染されているものだったら
体からすぐ早く壊れてしまう
それで癌になったりとかね
突然事故を起こしたりとか
それで早く死ぬ可能性もあります
で 人間頑張って頑張っていくら長生きしても
寿命が終わったところで死ななくちゃいけない
例えばすごい業を持って生まれる人がいる
人間の業と天界の業は同じなんです
例えば天界に生まれたら
もう四千年とかね 四千じゃない四万年とかね
生まれる寿命あるでしょうに
生きていられる寿命があるでしょうに
同じ業で人間に生まれるんです
ですから 業の力がそれなりにはあるんです
同じ業で天界にも生まれる
人間の世界にも生まれ変わる可能性あります
ということは 天界に生まれた天人が何万年もいられるんだから
カルマの力で 業の力で
我々にもそれぐらいの長生きできる可能性はあります
業にはあります 業にはあるんだけど
体がそうじゃないんですね
早く壊れてしまっちゃう
ですから死んでしまっちゃうんですね
そういうわけで 我々はいくら体を守っても守っても
まあ百二十歳ぐらいになっちゃうと
もうほとんど機能はもう見えなくなっちゃうし
聞こえなくなっちゃうし
食べたものは消化できなくなっちゃうし
死ななくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
この早く死ぬんだけど
この短い時間ですっごい活動して死ぬ人々がいるんですね
寿命短いんです その人々も
寿命は短いんだけど 膨大な業で生まれるんです
天界に生まれたならば
ものすごい高い次元の天界に生まれるぐらいの業を持っているんです
そこで人間に入り込んじゃうし
人間に入り込んじゃったんだけど
すっごいパワーを持ってるんですね
業の力が で 残念ながら寿命は短い
そこですごい活動する
天才みたい 活動しちゃうと体が早く壊れちゃうんですね
そういうものすごいね
まあ天才の人々が結構早く死んじゃうでしょうし
で それなりにもの人の百倍ぐらい仕事してるんでしょ
人はもう一生頑張ってやることを
この人々はまあもう半年間でやってしまっちゃいますからね
ですから 体の疲れはそれぐらいはあるんです
音楽書く人にしたっても
もう一年 二年 五年頑張って音楽一つ書いたと
一夜で書いたと やっぱり使うエネルギーは同じなんです
そういうわけで早く死んでしまっちゃうんですね
体が壊れて でもカルマが残っていると
かなり残っている 残ってしまう
だからそういう人々の名前は人間が覚えておくんです
いわゆる人が死んでも
その人をいまだにみんな思い出したり
尊敬したりする だからある程度ある面で死んでないんですね
例えば音楽家のね そういうベートーヴェンやらバッハやらね
そういう連中もね そうとっくに昔死んじゃったんだけどね
やっぱりいまだに人間の心の中で自分の存在感を残しておくんですね
それはもう徳が残っているんだから
お釈迦様も二千 もう六百年ぐらい前でもう
かももうちょっと六百年は経ってないかもしれませんだけど
亡くなったんだけど かなり力強く覚えているんですね
当時でおっしゃったことはいまだに厳密に勉強したりする
修行したりする それは膨大なカルマ
業が残っていて亡くなったんだから
早くこの歴史から消えるということはないんです
それでこの寿命が終わって死ぬ方々はそういう風に
カルマが残っている人々はそういうふうにいくらか理解できるんです
カルマが消えて全部終わって死ぬ人々は逆なんですね
早く死んでくれないかと
みんな思っているんです
死んだったら早くももう葬式たやら何やらすぐやってもう忘れる
そういう人々はもうカルマがもう終わって死んだと
寿命が終わってカルマが残って死ぬ人々は一応覚えているんですね
後の人々が 例えば親を・親のことを覚えている子供にしたっても
親が徳が高ければ親のことをずっと覚えているんですね
感謝して覚えている 親には何の徳もなかったならば
できるだけ早く忘れよう忘れようと子供は頑張っちゃうんですね
もう命日なんか忘れちゃうんです
誰かに思い あ そうか まあいいよ
忙しいんだから 仕事あるんだからやめようと
お墓参りも忘れちゃうと
そういう死に方ですね
最悪な両方なくなって死ぬ人々ですね
寿命も業も両方もなくなくて
死ぬ人々はもう まあ突然死ぬ人々はまあどちらでも残っているんだからね
いくらかはまあ覚えてる
例えばこの子供が早く時空を超越し死んだったと聞いたら
母親が自分死ぬまでその子供のことだけは忘れませんね
父親も母親もずっとものすごく可愛かったとかね
ものすごく頭が良くて勉強できてああだこうだとかね
そればっかりまあ思い出にしているしね
忘れようとはしない そういうこともあるしね
その場合はまあ両方残っているんですね
で 子供で死んじゃったんだからね
社会的に何も貢献できなかったんですからね
社会は忘れてるかもしれませんだけど
大体まあ両親兄弟ぐらいでも覚えてられると
そこで私たちにできることは
寿命が終わって死んでも
業が終わるまでは待ってはいけませんね
いわゆる我々 業はまたあるに・ある時
徳がまたたくさん残っている間で死ななくちゃいけない
そうでないともう大変不幸なんで死に方が
徳も消えちゃったらね
病院に行ってもお医者さんが面倒見てくれないし
で 徳を割ってるんだからね
例えば何かこういうものを食べなさい
こういう薬を使いなさいと言っても
もう薬局に行ったらその薬が切れているとかね
あるいはもう夜十一時とか十二時半とか一時半とかね
その時お医者さんが今この注射しなくちゃいけないんだからね
早くこの薬買ってこいと
どこから買ってくるんですか？その時は
病院にない場合は そういう風な
もうどうしようもない状態なんですね
やりきれないというかね
それも徳が切れてるということなんですね
そういうことはね 日本みたいなね
治療は完璧にできている国でもあり得るんですよ
例えばもうもう今酸素をつけてなんとかなんとかしなくちゃいけないというとこで見たところで
この技術屋さんがいないとかね
ものはあるんだけど それつけてくれる技術屋さんがいないと
すぐ病院のお医者さんに診てほしいんだけど
その瞬間でお医者さんがもっと他の患者さんにの面倒を見ていて
もう手がいてないとかね
その場合はもう徳の方がもうほとんど消えているんですね
そういうことで 人間はね
この贅沢するのは仏教反対はないんだけど
あまりにも贅沢三昧で生きていきてはいけないんです
そういう運命になるのはほとんど贅沢三昧の人々なんですね
わがままで贅沢三昧で
俺にはあるんだという感じでね
高価なものしか食わないぞとかね
高価な服しか着ませんよとかね
高価な車にしか俺は乗りませんよという頑固な人々が
最後はかなり嫌な存在で死んじゃうんです
ですから この何だかんだよ
仏教でいうのはこの中道で
ほどほどで このやらなくちゃいけない
かなり金持ちで かなり豊かで生まれても
それに奢れてはいけないんだと
いくらかのレベルで生活をして
残り分はお布施したり
人々のために使いなさいと
自分の徳なんですが 自分のために使う使ってはいけないと
自分積んだ徳だから 自分が豊かで生まれるんです
ですから ある面では全部自分に使う権利はあるんです
自分仕事をして儲かったお金だから
自分でそれでご飯食べて楽しく贅沢する権利はある
十分ありますけど かえって違う立場から見れば
それはちょっとよした方がいいと
適当に使って 余計余分はもう人のために使って徳を積むということをしなくちゃいけない
そうするともう幸福に生きていて
幸福に死なれる ということなんです
まあ簡単なことですからね
で もう時間になりましたし
あの三十三番目読んでみましょう
で 編集中の所縁の出陣
タターチャ・マラナンターナン・パナ・マラナカーレ・ヤターラハン・アビ・ムキーブータン・バワンタレー・パティサンディ・ジャナカーマン・ワー・タン・カッマ
・カッタ・カーレ・ルーパーディカン・ウパラッダ・プッバン・ウパカーナ・ブータン・チャ・カッマ・ニミッタ・ワン・ワ・アナンタ・アナンターラン・ウッパッジャ
・マーナ・バヴェー・ウパラビ・タッバン・ウパボーガ・ブータン・チャ・ガティ・ニミッタ・ワン・ワー・カッマ・バレーナ・チャンナン・ドワーラーナン・アンニャ・タラス・ミン・パッチュ・パッターティ
で 四つ見られるんですね
これパーリ語で言えばカッマ
カッマ・ニミッティ ガティ
ガティ・ニミッティと四つなんです
これは原文でなかなかそれ明確に書いてないんです
カッマ カッマ・ニミッティ
ガティ あ ニミットよりもっとパーリ語らしくしましょう
ニミット この四つ この死ぬ瞬間に
あの 見えるもの この四つの一つ
カンナはわかりますね
業ですね で 死ぬ瞬間で
自分が輪廻の中で今までやったありとあらゆる業の中で何か一つを心に映るんです
その何か一つ決める順番がこの前説明しましたね
ガルカ アーサンナ アーチンナ
カタッターという四つありますね
重い業をしたならば その重い業を映る
あるいは母親殺したり
父親殺したりとかね あるいは善女を作ったりとか
そういう重い業 重業したならば
それを映っちゃうんですね
重い業なければ ずーっとやってきたもの
じゃなくて 一番最近した行為を
一番最近したものを思い浮かぶ
まあそれは当たり前でね
すぐ思い出せますからね
一番最近した業を思い浮かぶ
最近した業がなければ
もうずーっとしてきたもの
慣れてきた業が思い浮かぶ
そういうものをなければ
何かの業が心に映っちゃうんですね
それは業ですね それで業が映る場合は
この行為自体思い浮かぶ時もあるし
あるいは二番目 カンマ
ニミット この業の何かこのニミットって何でしたっけ？相
業の相が何か見える 相っていうのは
例えば父親を殺したとするならば
死ぬ瞬間で父親はずっと見える
殺したことじゃなくて
ニコニコと自分の父親がいるのが見えるんですね
それが相なんですね 父親を殺したことを思い出すと業
父親見えると業の相 あるいは父親は野球バットで殺したならば
もう自分の目の前でずっといろんな野球バット
血がもういっぱいついている野球バットなんか見えるかもしれません
そうすると業相 例えば漁師の場合はね
まあ魚見えるかもしれませんし
網やら船やらそういうもの見えるかもしれませんし
業か業相かどっちか この朦朧とした状態だからもうコントロールできないんですね
我々にこうわからないんだから
この高熱出た時は頭の活動あるでしょ
ものすごい熱が出たらいろんなくだらないもの見えるわ
聞こえるわ あんな感じなんです
コントロールなしに で
三番目 ガティ ガティは何でしたっけ？うん？書いてないか
ん？ガティのことは言葉ないんです
ガティっていうのは次に生まれる場所
ですから 次に生まれる場所というか
その環境 なんとなく見える
そしたら 例えば人が死ぬ時はね
いろんな朦朧としてね
いろんなこと言うでしょ
そういうことなんです
言ったらもうものすごい怖いことばっかり思っていたならば
まあ怖いところに行く体格なんですね
死に瞬間でね 体が壊れてもう呼吸もできないのに
ニコニコとしてるならば
で なんかすごい元気でね
まあいいことしか何か言わない場合とかね
その場合はまあいいところに行く体格なんですね
うーん ですから この人のね
臨終の時は大体観察した方がいいです
死なないでくれ 死なないでくれ
頼むだよとかね 死なないでくれって言ったって死ぬと死ぬんだからね
そんな真顔で頼むのをやめて
ただその人を観察する
何かその人で何かやってあげることがあるならば
やってあげる それぐらいのことしかできないですよ
もしその人がずっと許されない怖いことをいっぱい何かするとね
まあその考え方をカットさせてもらって
清らかな楽しいことをね
思い浮かべられたりとか
そういうふうに何かね
心を清らかにしてあげると
あるいはまあ人生はね
まあよく頑張ってきたんだと
みんなの面倒を見てくれた
子供が生まれるというのは
よくしかないんだからね
よく生きたと親御さんは言ってるんだから
ですから もう最後にはもう
よく生きてきた人であろうともね
まあよく頑張ってきたんだからね
子供たちにも一応ね よく勉強できましたし
よく立派になったしね
まあおじいちゃんもよく頑張ってくれたんだと
そういう風にこの その人にこの人生について
この充実感を持って死ぬために何か喋ってあげると
心が清らかになる可能性はあると思います
例えば死ぬ時はね まあ父親か母親がね
自分がね 本当に残念ですよとね
子供たちにはもっと厳しくした方がよかったんではないかとか
後悔する可能性ある それは悪いところに行っちゃうわけですね
その場合は本当にいい親でいたかもしれませんよ
それでも死ぬ時はそう言ったらいけないんですね
そうですよ あんたもうちょっと厳しく子供に接した方がよかったんではなかったか
そんな言ったらいけないことなんです
その逆にもやっぱり厳しくした方がよかったんじゃないかと
そんな甘えて子供育てるのは
子供は良くならないんだと
これはまあ子供はまあ子供の自分のせいでね
まあうまくいかなかったかもしれませんけど
親としてはしっかり育てたんだからね
それしょうがないんだと
あんたはよく頑張ったんだという風に
もう褒めてあげなくてはいけないんですね
[咳]そうすると心はまあ星空の方向にいったんですね
まあとにかくこの死ぬ時は
禅宗の時はいろんなものを見えたりする
その見えるものは あの
次に生まれるところ 生まれる場所を見える時もあるし
あの何かその相だけ見える場合もあるし
例えば人間に生まれるんだったら
まあいろいろ場所ですね
例えばまあ日本で 日本でもまあ例えばなんですけどね
まあ山梨の方に生まれる予定だったら
まあ富士山見えると 富士山見えたりとかね
もうそちらの方なんかね
綺麗な湖 湖辺 そういうのが見えたりとか
そこら辺のね 農家を見えたりとかね
場所を見える あるいは道具見える
そう見える場合は 人間の場合がね
もう何かもう人間使ってる何か見えるんです
家見えると ベッド見えると
誰か人を見えるとか そういうふうに何かこの
だって生きてるとすぐ見えるんです
ですから 大体はね 人間の場合は
生まれる時はね 死ぬ時はね
まあどこに行くかなっていうことはわかります
このよっすい なんかそのことが気になっちゃう
気になって心から離れなくなっちゃう
そのどちらに見えるというと
目に見える あるいは聞こえる
六根にどちらかに入っちゃうんです
鼻に入る場合は香りに入っちゃうんだよね
あるいは天界に生まれるんだったら
もうこの世の中でないものすごい美しい柔らかな香りをかいだりする
その香りによってものすごい心の雰囲気が変わっちゃうんです
この香りがすごいもので
こんな優かな香りをかいだだけでものすごい心の雰囲気が変わるんです
よっしゃと その場合イメージ何も無いんです
まあこっち来る時に僕は歩き飛ばして座ったんだけど
あまりこの香りがもうよくないところで
もう人間のね もう牛なんかに生まれなんか人間の体から出る匂いっていうのはすっげえもんだなと思ったんだけど
すぐ他のところに行こうしな
確かにまあそこに座ってたっていうのもね
まあ構いませんけど 向こう側にはどうかなというところまであの場所をね
固めてるじゃない で まあ普通の人間に戻って
そしたらあのちょっと香りでもかいだだけで
その心の雰囲気っていうのはすぐ変わる
ですから 動物に生まれる人にとっては大体なんとかそれなりの香り
人間に生まれる人にとっては
例えば花の香りを [背景の雑音]